this here is a screenshot of the khan
academy unit circle module and the whole
point here is to get you familiar with
the unit circle definition of trig
functions which is just an extension
extension of the traditional sohcahtoa
definition but the reason why
math the math world did this is so that
we can define the sine and cosines of
angles that are 90 degrees or more or
that have actual negative angle measures
so let's figure out what the sine of 275
degrees is so we have this dot that's
sitting on a unit circle that has a
circle of radius one and let's get this
dot to 275 degrees let's make an angle
of 275 degrees with the positive x-axis
so let's see that's 50 degrees 75
degrees 90 degrees you see the angle
measure right over there
so 90 degrees 280 gets us halfway around
270 gets us at 3 4 of the way around so
275 is a little bit more than that and
we need to figure out the sine of 275
degrees the unit circle definition is
that the side of sine is that it's the y
value of that angle measure on the unit
circle so we've made the angle measure
we've gone 275 degrees counterclockwise
from the positive axis to get to this
point right over here and the y value is
this negative
0.996 that is the sine of 275 degrees
negative
0.996 if they had asked for the cosine
then we would give the x value of this
point of this
dot right over here so the y value is
negative 0.996 let's check our answer
very good let's do another one
and we get let's see sine of negative 55
degrees so now we're going to go
below the x-axis it's a negative angle
negative 55 degrees and sine once again
so we want to look at the x sorry the
y-coordinate of this point so where the
y-coordinate is negative 0.819
negative
0.819
check our answer very good let's keep
doing it maybe we'll see a cosine soon
enough sine of 285 degrees so 285
degrees we're looking right over there
the sine is the y value
negative 0.966
let's check our answer let's do another
one
sine again two-thirds pi so now it's in
radians we don't see that little degree
sign so two-thirds pi let's see two
two thirds pi is right over here that's
the angle in radians relative to the
positive x-axis going in the
counterclockwise direction we care about
the sine which is the y-value of our
point sitting on the unit circle
0.866
0.866 and one thing that bears mention
is the exact is square root of 3 over 2.
and square root of 3 over 2 if you were
to write as a decimal would just
continue on forever without actually
repeating this is just an approximation
for the sake of this module we really
just want to make you comfortable with
the unit circle and maybe using this
tool so you really should just type in
this approximate number you don't have
to do the exact number of what square
root of 3 over 2 is this is it rounded
to the nearest thousandth so
0.866 let's check our answer let's do
another one
sine again sine of 15 degrees
so 15 degrees 0.259
i'm going to keep doing this until i get
a cosine
so let's do it again cosine very good 2
pi 2 pi radians well 2 pi is completely
going around the unit circle once so
let's go all the way around and we see
that we get back to where we were before
we've gone around 2 pi radians we're
back to where we were before the cosine
is the x value of that point so the x
value of that point is 1.
the x value of the point is 1. if we
wanted the sine of 2 pi then we would
get 0 because we we have no y value
right over here we're at the x axis
let's check our answer let's do one more
maybe we'll see another cosine there we
go another cosine cosine of 1 12 pi so
that's just going to be a little let's
see 1 35 1 18 1 12. cosine we want the x
value not the y value the x value is
0.966
so
0.966
check our answer and we are done